What part are you in the music and
beat boxing. Can we hear something?
You want to try it?
This is hard.
Oh
wait, no. Uh, no. Do you?
Oh Man. I was just told like I'm going
to beat box with some producer. Okay.
I mean I just assume we're going
to make something. My name's Pete.
I'm a beat boxer. I go by Jay Luna
and I'm a producer, singer songwriter.
I just didn't know what to
expect,
you know,
like just walk in and I heard
that it's a music producer.
I have never worked with like a beat box.
I usually just sounds around me or just
like other like producers and stuff.
Okay. So you said you're
a beatboxer, right? Yeah.
That's a crazy sound you can make.
Do
what the
birds flying
beatboxing is making
rhythm with your mouth.
Right. And then you have like the
special effects, you know, like Whoa,
like what is that?
Definitely want to utilize all the
weird different sounds you can make.
And it's like really nice being a guy
who like dedicated pretty much the whole
life to like rhythm, you know? So
let's tous with one of your songs.
No, no, no. I'm embarrassed.
I showed you might beat box. I
guess I will. I guess I will.
I think his voice is Great.
It's more like a mellow kind of like wave.
Okay. I think we're all
set. Hey man, that was sick.
Oh, I see. Yeah, I think it'd be cool
for you. Like maybe record you first.
I think kind of play off that.
All right.
Like just put down some rhythms like
go through five or six like slow fast.
Hmm. Hmm. Hmm. Do you want
to do like a crazy role
that's not even humanly possible?
Let's compress the Shah.
Let's go.
He was definitely interesting to see how
he like reversed on the sound stretch.
Some sounds. Is that laser
sound for sure. Oh yeah.
Hello? Do you want to
hear a record? Some stuff?
Yeah,
sure.
How's it just all comes out like garbage.
I'm just kidding.
Hey,
nice to meet you. Nice to
meet you. So I'm from Nigeria.
I'm from Delta State in Nigeria.
I'm from Nigeria.
I'm from a non birthdays
ebook win. Hey. Hey.
Never made anything for like dancers.
I would like them to enjoy themselves
and feel comfortable dancing with them.
When I saw Jane, right? No, I was
like, what are these guys took up?
I don't know if they like
make African beats and stuff.
So I guess for like dancing to
whatever you guys come up with. Yeah,
I think that's, I think that's what
it is. That makes most sense to me.
So what part are you in the museum
be boxing you beatboxing that's so,
can we hear something?
Oh sure.
I can't,
you want to try it?
Is this a bunch of instruments in there?
He has a hole put in Bandon.
They're like, I've never made like a
beat box here before. What do I see?
How long have you been producing? Uh, I've
been through this for like three years.
Jay seems like an angel and he
just like grease everything. Okay.
Yeah,
definitely.
Just trying to figure out
like what kind of dancing do you
guys do or are solid dancing?
It's basically the afrobeats describe
it really fast with like, your health
has a lot of like the group to it.
It's more like the beats he get me.
Yeah.
It's not every day you
become a recording artist.
I think my favorite part was
probably recording the girls.
That's when it kind of felt like they
all kind of came together where like we
all kind of put it into a song and I
think that's the best feeling about
finishing. The whole credit
process felt really organic
to the Oakland, to the old
one. And that one man, Dad,
the guy like,
oh cool means waste the backside
basically I means is there.
So we'll put the homies though the bodies,
they're like the waste of there.
That's how you kept the crowd basically.
So yeah, they hear that and it's like,
it's time to dance.
You already know.
Well glad I go out of this one stems
more from South Africa and it's like, uh,
you've been your legging
and you bring your army.
Everything like bring it around
and then the shark or shark who is,
it's like you're moving, you're moving
and you can do it fast, do it for,
but didn't you pull your arms into it
and you're just rolling around with it?
That's so cool.
They were able to fuse our culture
and their cultures and their different
talents together to bring together
a beat that we were able to frank.
That's it.
I listened to the song and I'm like,
he blocks him to,
the ladies are like dancing right
there. Boom. Really sick to watch.
I'm definitely excited.
The communication was there.
It wasn't like really
rigid and like boring.
We were able to like
laugh with each other.
They joke with each other
about different things,
so I'm super excited about Lilly.
Me.
Oh, oh yeah. We got to this
amazing copy.
Who?
Five, six, seven, eight
come a little closer.
A little closer.
Come a little closer.
Mc.
Lyte
okay.
Ooh,
awesome.